straight ahead online crime daily
the retrial of an iowa mother accused of
strangling her daughter with a pair of
pajama pants
was it murder or an accident it's like
crushing a little flower
our experts weigh in plus a court
appearance for the man
accused of murdering his ceo boss then
dismembering the body in a luxury
manhattan apartment
and the woman charged with falsely
reporting an attack by a black man in
new york's central park
is trying to avoid jail time law on
crime daily covers court cases from
coast
to coast
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin a plea deal
appears in the works for the new york
woman captured on video calling 9-1-1
on a black man in central park
sorry i'm asking you to stop please
don't come close to me
sir i'm asking you to stop recording me
please don't come close to me please
take your phone off please don't come
closer please please call the cops
please call the cops i'm going to tell
them there's an african-american man
threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like i'm
being threatened by a man into the
ramble
please send the cops immediately amy
cooper appeared before a judge by a
video conference and we've learned she
might settle her case by agreeing to
community service if such a deal happens
it won't be finalized until cooper's
next court appearance about a month from
now
we've also learned that cooper called
the police not once but twice the day of
this video
claiming a black man named chris cooper
had in her words
tried to assault her when police arrived
however amy cooper admitted that chris
cooper who recorded the video
had not tried to assault her or even
tried to touch her
chris and amy are of course not related
despite having the same last name
everybody's seen the video everybody's
talked about this case so we of course
will as well brian
the charge here is falsely reporting an
incident in the third degree it's a
class a misdemeanor
what could that mean for amy cooper
legally a class a misdemeanor is
punishable by up to a year in jail
but actually how this plays out in most
of the five boroughs of new york
you're looking at a reduced charge
probably to a violation of disorderly
conduct
and some amount of community service
depending on what the size negotiate
so terry chris cooper who recorded the
video we just saw did not
support the new york district attorney's
decision to try to move forward with
this case he backed away from it said
she's gotten enough punishment from the
public shaming social media comments and
whatnot
my question legally though is does this
proposed punishment of community service
fit the crime given the outrage
i think it does not fit the crime the
da's office actually
said that the objective was to have the
proposed punishment educate both
ms cooper and the community but i
actually think that the punishment
should include
more accountability for her specific
actions this incident
really could have gone south fairly
quickly we've seen that happen in the
past and people could have been injured
or even worse yet people could have died
brian in your opinion does the
punishment fit the crime normally you're
in the position of defending people like
amy cooper
exactly when i look at other class a
misdemeanors and how they actually play
out in brooklyn or other areas
in the five boroughs it does actually
fit when you're talking about the level
of the crime
this is typically what happens with
class a misdemeanors or people who do
not have
large or any criminal history i do see
terry's point as to the ifs and maybes
that could have occurred
but if you're applying them all the same
way it's pretty par for the course
and the law operates the way the law
operates great analysis terry and brian
testimony has slammed to a hall in the
kelsey thomas murder trial she's the
iowa mother accused of strangling and
killing her little girl using a pair of
pajamas
a jury acquitted thomas in march of a
lesser count of child endangerment
resulting in death
but the jury hung on first degree murder
which carries a mandatory life sentence
it's the more serious charge
thomas is being tried again this time in
front of just a judge
prosecutors put the case on hold after
calling just
three witnesses terry austin is here to
bring us up to speed on one of those
witnesses terry
erin prosecutors called the investigator
who interviewed the defendant in 2018.
he testified from the jury box as a
covet 19 precaution
the agent said thomas was free to go at
any point during the half
five and a half hours of questioning
it was really we call the cognitive
style of interviewing
i simply would ask her to start the
interview by asking her to go through
the day's events
kind of tell me a story about what
happened in her best words using the
most recollection that she can the goal
is to let that individual talk as much
as she can so i can get an understanding
of what happened since i had never been
in the home and i had never talked to
her before
they're trying to indicate something in
that during that interview about wanting
to leave
i think at one point she she did stated
she wanted to leave and i recall that we
said well there's the door
you're welcome to leave she did not
the agent says he interviewed the
defendant again two days later
if i recall the the bulk of the
conversation we had with the defendant
was
the scenario in which she said how the
child was found
when she came into the bedroom with what
we saw as physical evidence or what the
medical examiner had provided to us
as information of if that act
hanging in the closet by a pajama pants
was plausible or not
at some point did the defendant change
her story
and confessed to
killing her daughter she did after that
uh portion of the interview did she ever
repent to you
no did she ever take any of what she had
said then back
no she did not at some point did you
provide um the defendant
a sheet of paper to write something down
i did after she had
confessed to killing her child we left
the room for a little bit she was alone
i offered her a piece of paper and said
would you like to write down your
thoughts people are going to have
questions of
what happened here would you want to
tell people what happened she took that
opportunity and did write a letter
eventually that same investigator
testified that he met with the medical
examiner
who had serious issues with how the
evidence compared with kelsey thomas's
claim
that chloe's death was an accident erin
thanks a lot for that report terry law
and crime expert and professor of
forensics joseph scott morgan analyzed
the autopsy photos and demonstrated
possible scenarios on how the victim's
injuries could have occurred
the markings that are left on the neck
are they consistent
with say this child being in a suspended
space
suspending an air and creating we call
it a tinting effect
where if you imagine this is the head
where it goes up
sharply like this as opposed to say
a ligature strangulation that runs more
parallel to the shoulders
so are these markings on the net
consistent
if you're going to strangulate your own
child
the reality of this uh is the fact that
you have to under most circumstances
stare them
in the face as you're doing it where
you're
on top of them throttling this child it
can be
accomplished from the rear but many
times you know we have this vision
of an individual that is on top of
of the victim uh you know she would so
overpower this child this is not like
adult
on adult you know just look at her she's
this
danny little angel it's not going to
take too much to overcome her
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily the state's final witness in the
kelsey thomas trial
is it evidence of murder or is it simply
inconclusive we'll let you decide
and later on this man's accused of
playing a role in the murders of eight
people
find out why he's writing to the judge
from behind bars while he awaits trial
law and crime daily will be right back
let's head back to court for more
testimony from the trial of kelsey
thomas the iowa mother accused of
murdering her five-year-old daughter
by strangling her to death kelsey thomas
says the girl died by
accidental hanging but kelsey thomas
also confessed after authorities
confronted her with an autopsy
was it a false confession brian
buckmeyer takes us through testimony
from the final witness
from the prosecution who described clues
that something just didn't feel right
about his interactions with the
defendant brian
yes aaron so a criminal investigator
testified that thomas's claim
that chloe died accidentally just didn't
make sense
in part based on thomas's own demeanor
one of those was with the manner in
which
ms thomas described how she had found
her daughter hanging
yet when she removed her daughter from
those pants the pants just simply fell
off the dowel rod
that was a point of concern for me it
seemed a little bit improbable
it seemed that if this was either an
intentional act or an accidental act as
ms thomas was describing it seemed like
there would have been a lot of avenues
for chloe to have gotten out of the
situation she was in
so i had a lot of questions about that
um
i did note uh that miss thomas um
through this walk through it did strike
me as odd that there really wasn't any
emotion involved in this
at this point we were less than 24 hours
removed from the death of her daughter
essentially
and there really wasn't any emotion
involved with this
essentially walking officers and
investigators through how she found her
daughter dead
the investigator also said that as
thomas walked him through her
home her description of how close how
chloe died
didn't add up chloe
while tying this knot she would have had
to have left enough room to fit her head
in
immediately just to get her head in and
then on top of that
i can't say what the factor would have
been but those pants are going to
stretch
it was very apparent to me that these
pants were considerably stretched out
in my opinion based on all the
measurements that were taken
were almost to a point where chloe would
have been nearly touching the ground
i just found it hard to believe that her
head would have just laid there and she
her muscles would have somehow just kept
her head in those pants
and not just you know her head flipped
back allowing her to fall out of that
there was just a lot of things that just
didn't seem like it would have worked
out the way she was describing
we really just felt strongly that
what she was describing just was not
plausible there was a lot
of information that had been looked too
into at that point
that just led us to really strongly
believe that you know we needed to
to really get to the bottom of the truth
essentially which we believed was
not what she was describing to us right
so the same investigator followed up
with the thomases
the day after chloe died and said he
found the parents behavior
very odd you noted a lack of emotion
in kelsey thomas correct correct you
noted that same lack of emotion in aaron
thomas her husband too
yes and ultimately you don't believe
aaron thomas was involved in
the death of huawei chandler correct
correct
thomas and kelsey thomas from an
emotional standpoint
essentially presented in a same and or
similar way
to you correctly i would say aaron
when he spoke he spoke uh
a little bit more abnormally um it's
hard for me to describe it
um it seemed like he had a little bit
more of a
little bit of a gut-wrenching feeling
but generally speaking i didn't see any
crying or anything like that from him
when kelsey was describing ravioli
coming out of chloe's mouth
during the walk through aaron laughed
correct
correct okay brian so we've got police
officers saying something didn't feel
right and look i understand that
the human urge to basically just trust
your instincts
but we hear testimony like this all the
time the question is how should the
defense deal with it when we're
getting testimony that oftentimes hinges
on a hunch
so i would say the officer keep your
feelings to yourself the only type of
witnesses that can use the o word that
being opinion
are experts and experts in those fields
joseph scott morgan
you can give your opinion all day long
because you're an expert in that
when this officer is testifying that
well i thought the pants would have
stretched
or is my opinion that her emotions were
this he's not a psychiatrist
he's not a forensic scientist and that
should have been dealt with motions and
lemonade to allow him not to testify to
that
terry sounds like we better hire brian
if we ever need somebody to combat this
testimony like this but
look this is a trial by judge not by
jury so the procedure just feels a
little bit odd for those of us who watch
trials all the time
nobody gave an opening statement the
state called three witnesses and
apparently plans to rest
the defense is calling one witness next
week
we're hearing that there's going to be
no closing argument that puts the burden
on the judge to read a lot of the files
and make sense of all of this
absolutely she's got to pay close
attention to what those files say
but remember she actually was the judge
who presided over
the first trial so she has the expertise
to remember
what the openings were what the closings
were what the arguments were and
actually what all the other witnesses
says and when it boils right down to it
it is the medical exam that really
matters here
yeah the whole case hinges on that
medical examiner do people believe that
testimony that the girl
died at the hands of her mother or
through an accident
that's what it hangs on and the judge
will have to make that decision
well let's move on to another case now
nearly two years after an ohio family
was ultimately charged a man was charged
rather i should say
with the execution-style murders of
another family
the patriarch charged wants a speedy
trial
george billy wagner his wife and his two
sons are charged with
killing eight members of the rodent and
gilly families in pike county in april
2016.
many of the victims were sleeping with
children and infants nearby when they
were killed
prosecutors claim a custody dispute was
the motive of all these killings
wagners have pleaded not guilty and
faced the possibility of the death
penalty
if they're convicted billy wagner filed
this two-page handwritten motion
without help from his attorney asking
for a speedy trial his lawyers say
they're still
waiting for prosecutors to turn over
discovery in the case
yesterday wagner's lawyers filed a
motion asking to withdraw what you're
seeing on your screen
wagner also signed the motion to
withdraw what he filed
he and his family have been held without
bail since november 2018.
and coming up after the break here on
law and crime daily find out why
prosecutors in missouri decided to
suddenly drop
a pending murder case and a man accused
of murdering his ceo
and dismembering the body appears in
court we'll have the details on that
case when long crime daily continues
[Music]
a former executive assistant to a tech
ceo has pleaded not guilty to charges of
first-degree murder for allegedly
decapitating
and dismembering his boss detectives say
fahim
saleh was attacked in his luxury new
york city apartment
saleh was an entrepreneur behind
successful startups
police announced the arrest of his
assistant back in july they say
tyrese haspel owed his boss tens of
thousands of dollars
haspel is also facing charges of larceny
burglary concealment of a corpse and
tampering with evidence here's how the
nypd described the gruesome murder
mr fahim sally's cousin discovered
his dismembered body in the living room
of his apartment
with his head arms and legs amputated
upon further investigation it was
revealed that on monday
july 13th at approximately 1 45
p.m mr sally was assaulted
by mr haskell with what appears to be a
conductive
energy weapon better known as a taser
while exiting an elevator into his
apartment
other news now a missouri man is now
free after spending 12 years behind bars
prosecutors in that state allowed donald
doc nash to walk free because they say
new evidence and revised expert opinions
resulted in reasonable doubt in his case
nash was convicted for killing judy
spencer in 1982
among the problems with the case new
technology revealed
two new male dna profiles on a shoelace
used to strangle the victim
neither of the profiles is those of doc
nash
in colorado authorities say they've
caught a killer who's been on the loose
for
almost 36 years in the murder of a
12-year-old girl a grand jury has
indicted stephen panke of murder and
kidnapping
they say he knew intimate details about
the killing
panky is even a failed candidate for
governor in idaho where he was arrested
the victim seen there jonelle matthews
was connected to the defendant through
church she was kidnapped officials say
and shot in the head
when we come back here on law and crime
daily an update on the case of the
state's highest law enforcement officer
under investigation
for striking and killing a man with his
car plus a bizarre case out of northern
new england involving the man police say
is in that car on your screen razor
blades
and a recall for pizza dough stick
around for that
personal capital
[Music]
a crazy case out of maine where a former
employee of a pizza dough company is
accused of putting razor blades in dough
for sale at a grocery store
38 year old nicholas mitchell waived
extradition after his arrest in
neighboring new hampshire
a store surveillance camera recorded a
man who appeared to be mitchell
tampering with packages of dough
mitchell faces several charges including
criminal threatening with a dangerous
weapon
and probation revocation he was
sentenced to two years in prison for a
20
in 2018 rather for a separate incident
that's the probation situation
no injuries have been reported and the
doe company has issued a recall just to
be safe
a police officer in cincinnati finding
herself on the wrong side of the law
a county grand jury there indicted
cynthia suiter on charges of
theft in office and unauthorized use of
property
prosecutors say suiter stole less than 7
thousand dollars worth of items
such as wallets from her departments
lost and found
she's been a police officer since 1998
her police powers have been suspended
while the case proceeds
south dakota officials have released a
9-1-1 call made by the attorney general
of that state
after he struck and killed a man with
his vehicle jason roundsburg
called police around 10 30 at night on
september 12th
saying he thought he hit a deer it
turned out he struck and killed
55-year-old joseph beaver
a toxicology report taken some 15 hours
after the crash reported no alcohol in
the state attorney general's system
according to the autopsy the victim died
of trauma consistent
with a pedestrian motor vehicle crash
brownsburg claims
he searched that night in a ditch with
his flashlight
and didn't find anything well ali i'm
the attorney general
and i am i don't know i hit something
you get something by highmore hi more
ends in the middle of the road
okay give me one second here let me get
you map
do you know where you're at i believe
i'm by high more
i can i'm right i can see the town i
think that time
i just went to it i am
west are you injured at all jason i am
not but my car sure as hell is
oh no okay do you think it was a deer or
something
i have no idea
let's talk about this one really quickly
so the ag makes that call
he's got the toxicology test much
many hours in the future but as for the
investigation
it's important how the investigation is
rolling out here and you have some
details on that
right i mean listen the good news is the
investigation is
not being handled by the attorney
general's office you heard that
telephone call obviously they're all
very sympathetic to him
but the investigation fortunately
because of
potential conflicts is being handled by
the south dakota
highway patrol and the north dakota
bureau of criminal investigation so
that is good news hopefully the
investigation will be as objective as
possible
yeah trying to get a little bit of
outside agency
attention on it there but again it's the
ag so brian does the story makes sense
that this was an accident
the thing that i think that really helps
this story make sense for the ag
is the fact that he's saying he searched
with officers that i think is gonna
boost the credibility of the story but
it seems peculiar that they couldn't
find anything or anyone
yeah i mean having the police there they
couldn't find anything either
maybe that will ultimately be the saving
grace for the ag if you're on his side
thanks for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time for
our discussions about justice
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all
good evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't
really jump to conclusions we break down
the case of a serial killer another day
of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is lawn crime
[Music]
you